التشابك الكمي يسمح للجسيمات بأن تكون مرتبطة بغض النظر عن المسافة بينها وهذا أمر غير بديهي لدرجة
أن حتى Einstein لم يعتقد أنه صحيح في حلقة اليوم من Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي سنتحدث عن كيف أن نظرية Bell
أثبتت أن Einstein كان
مخطئاً مرحباً بكم في Qiskit في الفصل الدراسي في هذه السلسلة سنستخدم Qiskit لاستكشاف بعض المفاهيم الأساسية التي تُغطى عادةً
في المقررات المتعلقة بالحوسبة الكمية كل فيديو سيكون مصحوباً أيضاً بوحدة تفاعلية
مرتبطة في الوصف أدناه فتأكدوا من الاطلاع عليها في فيديو العملات الكمية ناقشنا كيف أن قياس
التراكب الكمي هو عملية احتمالية بطبيعتها مثل رمي عملة معدنية من بعض النواحي لكن كيف نعرف
هذا هل يمكن أن يكون الجسيم الكمي يخفي سراً نتيجة محددة مسبقاً للقياس لكننا بطريقة ما نفشل في
التقاط هذه المعلومة في نظريتنا في الأيام الأولى لميكانيكا الكم كان هذا السؤال موضوع
جدال حاد بين فريقين رئيسيين في فريق كان Einstein الذي اعتقد أن ميكانيكا الكم غير مكتملة
أي أنها تفتقد بعض المتغيرات الضرورية لوصف النظام بشكل كامل اعتقد Einstein أن
هذه المتغيرات المخفية إذا تم اكتشافها ستحل بعض الجوانب التي تبدو متناقضة واحتمالية
في ميكانيكا الكم وفي الفريق الآخر كان Max Born حيث جادل Born
بأن الوصف الاحتمالي الذي تقدمه ميكانيكا الكم هو كل ما تحدده الطبيعة بمعنى آخر
الأمر ليس فقط أننا لا نعرف حالة الجسيم قبل قياسه بل إن الجسيم ليس له حالة محددة
قبل أن يُقاس لعقود اعتقد كثيرون أن هذا الخلاف كان سؤالاً فلسفياً قد لا يُحل
أبداً ففي النهاية لكي نتعلم أي شيء عن نظام ما نحتاج أن نقيسه كيف يمكننا أن نعرف
أي شيء عن طبيعة الحالة قبل قياسها ثم في عام 1964 وجد الفيزيائي
John Bell طريقة في ورقته البحثية فحص Bell الارتباطات الإحصائية بين قياسات زوج من
الجسيمات المتشابكة إذا كانت حالات الجسيمات قبل القياس محددة بواسطة بعض المتغيرات المخفية
غير المعروفة فقد وجد Bell أن ارتباطاتها لها حد أعلى ومن ناحية أخرى عندما حسب
الارتباطات التي تتنبأ بها ميكانيكا الكم وجد أنها تنتهك هذا الحد فقد وجد طريقة لكي
يميز مرة واحدة وللأبد بين وجهة نظر Einstein و Born وكل ما تبقى هو إجراء تجربة
فعلية لاختبار هذه الارتباطات مع جسيمات حقيقية لمعرفة ما إذا كانت تطيع إحصائيات المتغيرات المخفية أو أنها
تنتهك تلك القاعدة هذه الاختبارات أُجريت بدقة وتطور متزايد
على مر السنين وهي من أهم التجارب في الفيزياء الحديثة كانت رائدة لدرجة أنها
أكسبت ثلاثة فيزيائيين جائزة نوبل في عام 2022 لكن في هذه الأيام يمكن لأي شخص إجراء
اختبار Bell كل ما نحتاجه هو القليل من المعرفة بـ Qiskit والوصول إلى حاسوب IBM الكمي في هذا الفيديو سأقوم
بشرح منطق متباينة Bell ثم سأريكم كيف يمكننا اختبار تنبؤات Bell على حاسوب IBM
الكمي تتضمن متباينة Bell عدة قياسات مختلفة وطبقات من المنطق ويمكن أن تكون
صعبة المتابعة قليلاً لكننا سنمر عليها خطوة بخطوة وفي النهاية ستكون تستحق العناء نحن على وشك أن نُثبت
أن التشابك حقيقي وأن Einstein كان مخطئاً وهذا ليس شيئاً يستطيع كثيرون القول بأنهم فعلوه إذاً إليكم
ما اقترحه Bell لنفترض أن لديكم طريقة لإنتاج نسخ كثيرة من زوج متشابك من الجسيمات فيزيائياً
يمكن إنتاج هذه الأزواج من خلال عملية اضمحلال حيث يتحلل جسيم واحد إلى اثنين إذا شاهدتم الفيديو عن
تجربة Stern-Gerlach تعلمون أن الجسيمات يمكن أن يكون لها زخم زاوي ذاتي يُسمى
اللف المغزلي لنقل أن جسيماً واحداً ذا لف مغزلي صفر يتحلل إلى جسيمين ذوي لف مغزلي 1/2
عندها كل جسيم ذي لف مغزلي 1/2 يمكن قياسه ليكون إما زائد 1/2 أو ناقص
1/2 ويُسمى أيضاً لف مغزلي لأعلى أو لأسفل ولكن بما أنهما تحللا من جسيم ذي لف مغزلي صفر فيجب أن يتحدا ليكون
مجموع لفهما المغزلي صفراً أيضاً فإذا قيس أحدهما لأعلى يجب أن يكون الآخر
لأسفل والعكس صحيح هذه الجسيمات تشكل زوجاً متشابكاً يبدو هكذا
فإذا قيس أحدهما لأعلى يكون الآخر لأسفل والعكس صحيح لنقل أن الجسيم الأول ينطلق نحو اليسار أي
في اتجاه سالب X حيث يقوم باحث نسميه Lucas بقياس
لفه المغزلي ثم ينطلق الجسيم الثاني بالمثل نحو اليمين
حيث يمكن لباحثة أخرى Rihanna أن تقيس ذلك اللف المغزلي يستطيع Lucas و Rihanna بشكل مستقل
تدوير أجهزة القياس الخاصة بهما لاختيار قياس اللف المغزلي لجسيماتهما على أي اتجاه
عمودي على اتجاه حركة الجسيم إذا أرسلنا نسخاً كثيرة من الحالة المتشابكة إلى Lucas
و Rihanna يمكنهما جمع إحصائيات القياس إذا قاسا دائماً على نفس المحور فلن تكون هذه الإحصائيات
مثيرة للاهتمام كثيراً كل مرة يقيس أحدهما لف مغزلي لأعلى يقيس الآخر لأسفل وكل مرة يقيس أحدهما لف مغزلي
للأمام يقيس الآخر للخلف وهكذا لكن إذا قاس الباحثان على محاور مختلفة قد نجد
شيئاً أكثر إثارة للاهتمام لنعطي Lucas و Rihanna ثلاثة محاور للقياس
عليها سنسمي هذه المحاور a و b و c وكل منها يفصله عن الآخر
120 درجة السؤال الذي سنطرحه في هذه التجربة هو إذا كان Lucas و Rihanna أحراراً في القياس على أي من المحاور الثلاثة
كم مرة سيحصل الاثنان على نفس الإشارة من الواضح أنه إذا قاس Lucas و Rihanna صدفةً على نفس المحور
مثلاً المحور a فلن يحصلا أبداً على نفس الإشارة لأن الجسيمات يجب أن تتحد لتعطي لفاً مغزلياً صفراً لكن عندما يختاران
محاور مختلفة كيف ستكون قياساتهما مترابطة إن كانت كذلك وفقاً لـ Einstein هذا الوصف الكمي
الميكانيكي لحالة الجسيم غير مكتمل اعتقد أنه يجب أن توجد متغيرات مخفية تحدد
مسبقاً نتيجة جميع قياسات اللف المغزلي الممكنة لأنه بدون ذلك سيتعين على الجسيمات المتشابكة أن
تتواصل بطريقة ما لتنقل نتيجة قياسها لبعضها البعض فورياً إذا قيس أحدها
لأعلى هنا يجب أن يعرف الآخر فورياً أن يكون لأسفل هناك
هذه المتغيرات المخفية قد تكون أي مجموعة معقدة من التعليمات لنتائج التجارب لكن المهم هو
أن حالة اللف المغزلي لكل جسيم على حدة محددة مسبقاً فلا حاجة لأي تواصل
تجريبياً هذا يعني أن القياسات التي يجريها Lucas لن يكون لها أي تأثير على جسيم Rihanna والعكس
صحيح وهذا قد يضع بعض الحدود على مدى ارتباط القياسين لكن وفقاً لـ Born فإن هذه الحالة
psi هي كل ما يمكن قوله عن زوج الجسيمات قبل القياس وبالتالي فإن قياس جسيم واحد
يؤثر على نتيجة قياس الآخر وهذا قد يكون له آثار مختلفة على الارتباطات بين القياسات دعونا نرى كيف تؤثر كل
نظرية على هذه الارتباطات في معالجة المتغيرات المخفية توجد مجموعة سرية من التعليمات قبل
القياس تحدد مسبقاً ما سيقيسه Lucas على كل من المحاور الثلاثة مثلاً هذه
التعليمات قد تكون موجب إذا قاس Lucas على المحور a
موجب إذا قاس على b وسالب إذا قاس على c يمكننا
كتابة هذا كـ زائد a زائد b وناقص c عندها جسيم Rihanna
سيحتاج أن تكون متغيراته ناقص a ناقص b وزائد c للتأكد من أن اللف المغزلي الكلي
على أي اتجاه واحد هو صفر
هناك ثماني مجموعات ممكنة من التعليمات تحقق شرط اللف المغزلي الصفري فكل مرة يُرسل فيها زوج جديد من
الجسيمات إلى Lucas و Rihanna قد يحتوي على أي مجموعة من هذه المجموعات الثماني والآن نريد أن
نعرف بافتراض أن الجسيمات تحتوي على إحدى مجموعات التعليمات السرية المعطاة في الجدول و
بافتراض أن Lucas و Rihanna يختاران بشكل مستقل أياً من المحاور الثلاثة للقياس عليه ما هو
احتمال أن يقيس كلاهما نفس الإشارة إذا كانت التعليمات هي تلك المعطاة في الصفين 1 أو
8 فمن الواضح أن هذا الاحتمال هو صفر لأن الجسيمين سيكون لهما إشارات متعاكسة بغض النظر عن
محاور القياس لكن ماذا عن التعليمات في الصف الثاني سيقيسان نفس الإشارة إذا
قاست Rihanna على c و قاس Lucas على إما a أو b أو إذا قاس Lucas
على c و قاست Rihanna على إما a أو b فهذا أربعة من أصل تسعة من
مجموعات القياس الممكنة التي ستعطي Lucas و Rihanna نفس الإشارة إذا فعلنا هذا لكل
مجموعة من التعليمات سترون أن الصفوف من 3 إلى 7 تعطي أيضاً احتمال 4/9 وهذا يعني أنه إذا كان
Einstein محقاً وأن متغيرات مخفية كهذه تحدد مسبقاً نتائج القياسات فلا يمكن لـ Lucas
و Rihanna أبداً أن يقيسا نفس الإشارة باحتمال أكبر من 4/9 هذه هي متباينة Bell أن P أقل من
أو يساوي 4/9 وكما سنُظهر فإن الجسيمات المتشابكة تنتهك هذا لنرى
ما تتنبأ به ميكانيكا الكم لنقل أن Lucas يقيس على المحور a هناك أمران يمكن أن يحدثا إما أن يقيس لفاً مغزلياً لأعلى فتقيس
Rihanna لفاً مغزلياً لأسفل على a أو يقيس لفاً مغزلياً لأسفل فتقيس Rihanna لفاً مغزلياً لأعلى على a لكننا
نريد احتمال أن تقيس Rihanna نفس إشارة Lucas على أي محور تختاره وليس فقط a إذا
قاست على إما b أو c يصبح الأمر معقداً بعض الشيء واتضح أنه
إذا عرفت ما ستقيسه Rihanna بيقين 100% على اتجاه واحد فيمكنك حساب احتمالات
أن تقيس لأعلى أو لأسفل على أي محور آخر بقليل من الهندسة
إذا كانت حالتك تقيس دائماً لفاً مغزلياً لأعلى على محور واحد فإن احتمال قياس لف مغزلي لأعلى على محور مختلف
يساوي مربع جيب تمام نصف الزاوية بين المحورين هذا معقد بعض الشيء لكن
سأوضح لكم ما أعنيه إذا قاس Lucas لفاً مغزلياً لأعلى على a نعلم بيقين 100% أن Rihanna ستقيس
لفاً مغزلياً لأسفل إذا قاست على a فيمكننا تمثيل ذلك بمتجه
هكذا في هذه الحالة الزوايا بين هذا المتجه ومحوري القياس الآخرين b و c كلاهما
60 درجة فنصف ذلك هو 30 درجة وجيب تمام
30 موضح هنا مربع جيب تمام
30 درجة يساوي 3/4 الآن ماذا لو قاس Lucas لفاً مغزلياً لأسفل
على a نعلم أن Rihanna ستقيس لفاً مغزلياً لأعلى على a فيمكننا رسم متجه آخر هنا الآن
هذا المتجه الذي يمثل هذه المعرفة يبعد 120 درجة عن كل من المحورين الآخرين b
و c فيمكننا استخدام نفس الحيلة الهندسية لكن هذه المرة سنحصل على جيب تمام
60 درجة فمربع جيب تمام
60 درجة يساوي 1/4 بما أن Lucas من المرجح بالتساوي أن
يقيس لفاً مغزلياً لأعلى أو لأسفل على a نحتاج لحساب متوسط هذين الاحتمالين لـ Rihanna وننتهي باحتمال نهائي
أن تقيس Rihanna نفس إشارة Lucas يساوي 1/2 إذاً P
يساوي 1/2 وهو أكبر من 4/9 إذاً متباينة Bell منتهكة
هذا يعني أنه طالما قواعد ميكانيكا الكم صحيحة فإن المتغيرات المخفية مستحيلة الآن يمكننا استخدام Qiskit و
حاسوب IBM الكمي لاختبار متباينة Bell بقياسات كمية حقيقية يمكننا ربط حالتي اللف المغزلي لأعلى و
لأسفل لجسيمات Lucas و Rihanna بحالتي الصفر والواحد لـ qubit في الحاسوب الكمي سنأخذ
qubit اثنين واحد يمثل جسيم Lucas وواحد لجسيم Rihanna ونشبكهما بهذه الـ circuit الكمية
الـ qubit الاثنان ممثلان بالسلكين q0 و q1 وهذه المجموعة
من gate الـ X و Hadamard و CNOT ستنشئ نفس الحالة المتشابكة التي كانت بين جسيمات Lucas و Rihanna الآن
نحتاج لقياس كل qubit سنضبط قياس Lucas ليكون على المحور a الذي سنقول إنه محور Z ثم قياس Rihanna
يمكن أن يكون على a أو b أو c فسنحتاج ثلاث circuits منفصلة لكل من هذه الحالات الثلاث لكن في هذا
الفيديو سنفعل واحدة فقط يمكنكم الذهاب إلى الوحدة المرتبطة في الوصف للنسخة الكاملة إذا قاست Rihanna على
b فإن الـ circuit تبدو هكذا حيث ry هو دوران بمقدار 120 درجة لتغيير
محور قياس Rihanna يمكننا استخدام Qiskit Primitive sampler لتشغيل هذه التجربة عدة مرات وجمع
الإحصائيات من القياسات الناتجة العمودان 0 0 و 1 1 يمثلان المرات التي قاس فيها Lucas و
Rihanna نفس الإشارة وهو ما نبحث عنه فاحتمال قياس كلا الجسيمين بنفس
الإشارة قريب جداً من 1/2 وهذا ينتهك متباينة Bell وهذا يعني
أن الجسيمين متشابكان وكل منهما يبدو أنه يعرف فورياً نتائج
قياس الآخر لا يزال هناك بعض الخلاف حول كيفية تفسير هذا
التشابك وماذا يحدث عندما تقيس حالة متشابكة لكن هذه الأسئلة فلسفية أكثر
النظرية لا يمكن إنكارها في هذه المرحلة التشابك حقيقي بالتأكيد ونحن نعلم هذا بفضل Bell ومتباينته
والعديد من الفيزيائيين الذين أجروا تجارب لاختباره إذا كنتم تريدون أن تُحسبوا من بين هؤلاء
الفيزيائيين وتجروا اختبار Bell الخاص بكم مع حاسوب كمي تأكدوا من التوجه إلى وحدة متباينة Bell
المرتبطة في الوصف شكراً للمشاهدة وأراكم في المرة القادمة